and the Grammy goes to bad guy Billy I
live
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
from Billy eyelashes big sweets too many
powerful performances and touching
tributes et is taking a look at the most
memorable moments from the 2020 Grammy
Awards tonight is for Kobe the show
kicked off with a performance by Liz o
who set the tone for a night of
commemorating Kobe Bryant who died in a
helicopter crash Sunday morning host
Alicia Keys addressed Kobe's death at
the top of the show we never imagined in
a million years we'd have to start the
show like this never never never never
never never
it was painful it's painful right now is
still painful and we lost a beloved
beloved hero to all of us a person who
is like a true example of brilliance and
excellence
the singer paid tribute to the late
basketball star by doing what she does
best sing alongside voice two minute
[Music]
this is a very very tough day how did
this come together in about ten minutes
we got the phone call that at least you
wanted to do this special tribute
unfortunate tribute for Kobe it's an
honor as well as a tragedy he's gonna be
remembered as one of the greatest that
ever did it when you say that life is
unfair it's just unfair and we don't
know why and all we can do is pray and
ask God for the understanding to why he
does what he does several artists
honored number 24 during their
performances like Aerosmith and Run DMC
and lil nas ex who had Kobe's iconic
Jersey on full display
rest in peace Jacoby we definitely
wanted to do something cuz you know it's
unfortunate you know that this happened
on this day and while we're at this
place and yeah you know the 20 year old
rapper who took home two Grammys gave us
the mega collab we didn't know we needed
joining him to perform Old Town Road
Billy Ray Cyrus BTS Diplo and Maison
Ramsey and surprise nas get it little
nas X and NAS on the same stage I felt
the energy some things didn't go as
planned but we kept moving on but the
night belonged to Billy Eilish who swept
the show taking home five awards
including the big four Best New Artist
record song and album of the year we
didn't make this album to win a Grammy
we didn't think it would win anything
ever we wrote an album about depression
and suicidal thoughts and climate change
and check this out here's Billy mouthing
please don't be me before her name was
called she even said on stage she didn't
think she deserved it can I just say
that I think Arianna deserves this and I
think it deserves like more than
anything in the world I love you so much
beyond your wildest dreams
this is a real this is like a dream oh
my god yeah how do you take in this
moment oh you don't know a couple years
from now will be like remember that one
time no you don't take it in you just
you just people there were tears from
Demi Lovato who performed for the first
time since her 28th teen drug overdose
the experience was so overwhelming she
we started her performance after tears
immediately flooded her eyes
[Music]
a big theme of the night family after
walking the red carpet with both of her
parents ariana grande changed the lyrics
of her song Thank You next
giving her dad a sweet shout-out Camila
Cabello had a special moment with her
dad singing the song she wrote about
their relationship first man
[Music]
it's you know
[Music]
Tyler the Creator won the Grammy for
Best Rap Album and adorable his mom
joined him on stage Tyler what is what
does this mean Wow shiny I'm very
excited they cut they gave me to wrap it
up music that was tight
I'm so happy I got that where's your mom
I don't know I do not know where she is
I'm kind of I'm happy she came on but I
always keep my family super secret so
when she came on I was like no but like
it was all love everything was great I'm
hyped I'll probably go and do what I
normally would do on a Sunday night no
you're not your Grammy winner now you're
gonna go crazy ha ha ha thanks so much
and Blake Shelton and Gwen Stefani
filled the room with love performing
their duet nobody but you
[Music]
when how was it it was very emotional
after what Alicia was saying in Copiah
it was incredible though and I'm so
grateful to be here whoo look at this
that's not just from years of drinking
that's from performing with Gwen Stefani
on the Grammys there were also the
emotional tributes to Nipsey Hussle and
Prince what a moment huh you knew what
would Prince of thought because he
wasn't he wasn't high on a lot of people
doing his stuff but I think he would
have loved this moment no he would have
loved it he doesn't like the attention
he never did but I mean to pay tribute
to him like this he would have been
really proud and there are a few people
who could have done what usher just did
up there only he could do what he just
did
[Music]